- What is the length of arc ABC?
So arc ABC is this arc right over here,
and the reason why they have to give us
three points because if they just said
arc AC, it would still be ambiguous
because there's two arc AC's.
It could be this arc right over here
or it could be this arc over here.
So when they tell us B we know
that we're going from A to C
through B, so that's why
this kind of giving us that third letter
resolves the ambiguity on which
arc we're talking about.
So what is the length of that arc?
Well the first thing we could do is,
let's just think about the entire,
what's the circumference of this circle?
And then we can say what fraction
of the entire circumference is this arc?
And a big hint here is if we were
to go all the way around the circle
that would be 360 degrees,
but we're only going 135
of those 360 degrees.
Let's think first think
about the circumference.
So, the circumference
of a circle is equal to
two pi times the radius of the circle,
and they give us the
radius as three inches.
So the circumference is going to be
two pi times three inches,
so times three inches,
or two times three is six times pi.
So it's going to be six pi, six pi inches.
Now, and actually if you look at the....
If you look at the choices over here
the entire circumference of
the circle is six pi inches.
Remember pi is 3.14159,
so this is going to be
something in the...
It's going to be a little
bit over 18 or 19 inches.
So you could immediately...
If the entire circumference
is a little over
18 or 19 inches, this is only a fraction
of that entire circumference.
So actually if you were even looking
at the choices you'd
say, "Well hey, these are
way too large."
But I still see if we could get to
the exact right answer.
So the entire circumference
is six pi inches
but this arc length isn't
the entire circumference.
It only goes 135 degrees
out of 360 degrees.
So we could say...
So it is 135 360th
of the entire circumference.
Remember, if we were to
go all the way around
that's 360 degrees, while
this angle right over here
is 135 degrees, the angle
that is subtended by this arc.
So this arc length is
going to be 135 out of...
135 360th of the entire circumference.
So times, times six pi,
six pi inches.
Let's see if we can
simplify this a little bit.
Let's see...
We could divide the
numerator and the denominator
by six, six divided by six is 130...
360 divided by six is 60,
and let's see, if we divide
135 by five, that is going to be
27, yeah.
100 divided by five is 20,
and then 35 divided by five is seven
so this is going to be 27,
and then this would be 12.
We divide 60 by five.
Let's see, we can then
divide the numerator
and the denominator by three.
27 divided by three is nine,
and 12 divided by three is four.
So we're left with nine
fourths times pi inches.
So nine fourths times pi inches.
or we can multiply the
numerator times the pi.
We could say nine pi over four inches.
When you look at the choices
that is this one.
That is this one right over there.